so i was not going to talk about this
because i genuinely didn't think that it
would need debunking that it would need
a discussion but sadly it does because
there is a new ivermectin and again
study i hate to use the word study and
you'll see why shortly because really
what we're talking about is a conference
abstract but there is a new purported
ivermectin study
which all sorts of right-wingers
including jordan peterson and others
have been promoting and saying look
here's the proof here's the proof that
ivermectin this cheap drug
uh is good for preventing death from
covid they've been covering it up and we
got it we got the information however
even the author of the paper says that's
not what the paper says
we have retracted the paper and there
are now actual better studies on this
matter and people need to stop pointing
to his paper
as proof
that ivermectin works to prevent death
from covid now as many of you might know
if we want to test whether a medication
or treatment is worth using against a
particular disease or condition
the gold standard is a double-blind
randomized controlled trial which
compares the treatment you're testing
against the standard of care at the time
meaning the best known treatment that's
available at the time so for ivermectin
you would take a group of people
you would ensure that there are no
different differences between the groups
in terms of characteristics or that
you've
equalized or adjusted for those
differences and characteristics
you'd give half ivermectin you'd give
the other half the standard of care
the doctors shouldn't know who's getting
what the patients shouldn't know who's
getting what and you compare the
outcomes does one group have a different
outcome than the other
we actually have an rct randomized
controlled trial on ivermectin as i told
you about back in february that study is
called efficacy of ivermectin treatment
on disease progression among adults with
mild to moderate covid19 and
comorbidities
that study a good study a properly done
study found
that ivermectin doesn't work for
treating covid for preventing death from
covid so we had that study it was a very
good study and we thought it was finally
time to put the issue to bed
but there is a new study but it's not
really a study it's a conference
abstract and it's actually months old
based on even older data which is being
wildly distorted to claim that
ivermectin is extraordinarily
efficacious for preventing covet deaths
now as a reminder i would love it if
that was the case because ivermectin's
really cheap if ivermectin were really
effective at preventing death from covet
i would be thrilled i have no
ideological horse in this race
whatsoever but we have one good rct that
says ivermectin doesn't work
we've got to be really sure we have
something that gives us a different
perspective well a lot of
folks on the internet think it does dr
john campbell who's not a medical doctor
important to remind you
has been pushing the study in a video
called ivermectin more evidence that
nearly has a million views right now
dr pierre corey another darling for the
ivermectin supporters has pushed it
tweeting quote
massive study comparing the mortality
rates of patients treated with
ivermectin and those treated with room
remdessevier shocker
large magnitude reduction in mortality
if treated with ivermectin the united
states of pharma rages on
jordan peterson pushing the study
tweeting
this should be a bombshell treatment
with ivermectin is associated with
decreased mortality in covid compared to
remdessevier
they are distorting and misusing the
report and even its author says so the
author actually responded to each of
these people with comments similar to
this one this comment was a response to
jordan peterson where yaakov befamenko
the first author of this paper
says quote hi dr peterson first author
of the paper i think the information and
data is being crudely misrepresented and
misinterpreted this is an abstract not
peer-reviewed from a conference i
presented at we did not submit the
manuscript for a reason weak evidence
okay
if it really were shown to work
that would be great
but that's not what its own author says
this conference abstract is called
uh abstract i'm sorry this is from the
eighth international meeting on emerging
diseases and surveillance
and this is a particular abstract about
ivermectin it is months old and it is
based on data that's even older than
that
since then we've gotten an actual
randomized controlled trial
this paper is a retrospective study and
it compares people who took
remdesseviere to people who took
ivermectin based on everybody's
recollections without even knowing what
doses of different things people
received the paper was also withdrawn
the paper was withdrawn
and what people are claiming the study
shows is that if you got ivermectin
you're 70 percent less likely to die
than if you got redesire but the problem
is
number one it's a retrospective study
looking at stated data from the past
about this
they didn't stratify the patients by
vaccine status we don't know
whether the same portion of the people
who got ivermectin
uh are uh whether the same portion of
people who got ivermectin were
vaccinated versus the portion of those
who got remdessevier were vaccinated we
don't know that the study didn't look at
that they didn't stratify for
seriousness of disease in other words
it's possible that the people who got
room desevere got it because they were
more sick
so of course they were more likely to
die this wasn't double blind it wasn't a
randomized controlled trial now if you
don't believe me
here's the co-author of the paper saying
this
that this is not
good for determining whether to use
ivermectin here's jakob efemenko of
course there are also many potential
confounders
co-factors and so on confounders that
are difficult to account for
in like a large
retrospective observational study you
can't account for data that's not
collected and confounders aren't there
is that a concern of yours in terms of
the strength of the inference from the
study
uh yeah absolutely i mean that's
something that we elaborate on in the
full manuscript that i wrote that we
ended up withdrawing um
because you just don't have the space
you know you're limited to four or five
hundred words in an abstract you can't
elaborate any of those things if you're
trying to convey any kind of point
across um but in the full manuscript
that we wrote
some of the things that i wrote down
here
i'll go over uh so limitations obviously
it's like a retrospective study so we
cannot exclude possibility of
confounding factors as just the nature
of retrospective studies um treatment
dosage with ayurvectin was
widely varied there is no unified
protocol
like who knows
how much fibromax in each patient was
receiving um
because trinetics doesn't have a way to
you know screen for
dosages at that time at least
there is significant limitation for the
ability to control for cov19 vaccination
basically uh we were unable to do that
and that's something we also wrote in
the manuscript
um
so yeah basically vaccination status was
unaccounted for um
because trinity trinetics was unreliable
for that because you know people get
vaccines at a gas station here in
florida or like the church or whatever
so pretty much anywhere that doesn't go
in your emr
um and also i think most importantly
uh we weren't able to stratify patients
based on severity of disease um at that
time
um you know it's very possible that like
patients that were receiving severe had
a much more complicated course of
disease compared to patients receiving
hyvermax and i think that's like one of
the major confounders of that study
i've seen that discussed a little bit in
the discussions so that's the author
saying
we withdrew it
we withdrew it
it wasn't peer-reviewed
we didn't even know what dose of
ivermectin people were getting the
studies being misused there was no
control for vaccine status there was no
control for severity of disease this is
not a random critic this is not you know
whoever
this is
the first author of the paper saying
it's not good data it's old data from a
conference in november and we now have
actual rcts on ivermectin so just bear
this in mind because you'll see you'll
go to different subreddits and you'll
see it on twitter you'll see youtube
videos people saying look at this study
withdrawn
non-peer-reviewed
conference abstract of a retrospective
analysis of data
don't forget
i would love it if this worked
this paper is not evidence that it does
if you're like me you love documentaries
and you should really check out our
sponsor curiosity stream the only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries curiosity stream has a
better selection of documentaries than
netflix hulu and amazon they always have
the newest and most critically acclaimed
titles including a bunch of stuff i
can't find anywhere else i just finished
watching fiddling it's about bluegrass i
know so little about bluegrass
it's pretty fascinating and i watched a
documentary about it fiddlin
i've been using curiosity stream for
over a year i always have it going on my
tv in the evenings you really can't run
out of the amazing content constantly
adding new stuff if you want to deep
dive into a thought-provoking new topic
they have documentaries if you just want
to unwind and turn your brain off
they have documentaries there as well
right now curiosity stream is giving my
audience 25 off that comes out to just
14.99
a year a year that's just a dollar 25 a
month go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below